butler right there with him back up top
to bledsoe
[Applause]
bledsoe top of the key got it rattles at
home with the bucks retake the lead
and then bledsoe's had some struggles
with his perimeter shot
here gets one to bledsoe with eight
boards drives gets in the paint kicks it
back out
lopez three-pointer punch it in well
bledsoe with the deep penetration he
finds
by the way there were two people at our
division three games
jimmy butler in the paint throws it up
and in cuts it a two
[Applause]
jimmy butler drives back for adebayo
throws it up shot bounces around and
drops through
26 for adebayo when the game is tied
well a good read by butler that's just
good rotation
does he have the legs to finish lopez
against adebayo
throws it up shots good the heat trying
to put away the
pesky bucks dragach floats it up autobio
rebound
back out hero hero dragach
inside out of bio kicks it back out hero
for three
bang whoever said a hero ain't nothing
but a sandwich is a liar
he's a knock down shooter and put his
team in position
pulls back back to adebayo has to get
the shot off drives inside throws it
down
while it comes off this screen has a
wide open shot turns it down
doesn't settle in credit talked about a
lot of patience
tells brook lopez mano business
[Applause]
middleton's jumper puts it in again his
minutes have been extended maybe a
little bit
fatigued but finds a way seven
middleton on the drive the floaters up
shots good
tyler hero for three puts it in hero
does it again
middleton for three bang chris middleton
from downtown
and the bucks go back up by four